فيما بدا انه استعداد لنزال بعد الجدل
الاخير بين مارك زاكور وايلون ماسك
ظهر مالك ماتا في صوره تدريبيه على
الالعاب القتاليه
ونشر مارك زوكربيرج صوره له عبر حسابه على
انستجرام رفقه لاعب الفنون القتاليه بعد
تمرين على القتال
صوره المنتشره شهدت تفاعلا كبيرا من رواد
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي فيما تؤكد انباء
فيما اكدت انباء ان مارك يتدرب على عده
فنون قتاليه منذ فتره
وقد كان دار حوار شهير بين ماسك ومارك
الشهر الماضي حول اقامه نزال بينهما قبل
ان يطلق مارك مفاجاته لايلون ماسك باطلاق
تطبيق
المشابه لتويتر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات